queremos encontrar el área que queda por
debajo de la curva
a la raíz de x pero por arriba de la
curva
x al cuadrado osea queremos determinar
esta área de acá esta área
afortunadamente sabemos en qué punto se
intersectan estas curvas este punto de
acá es el 0 0 y este punto de acá es el
11 ya que si ponemos x igual a 1 aquí
nos queda 1 al cuadrado que es 1 y aquí
también nos queda a raíz de 1 que es 1 y
por lo tanto las curvas intersectan en
este punto así una forma de pensar en
esta región que queremos es tomar el
área que está por debajo de la curva
naranja entre 0 y 1 y a eso restarle el
rosa vamos a ver que nos queda entonces
el área que queda por debajo de la curva
naranja déjame marcar la esta de acá
esta de acá la podemos poner en términos
de una integral nos quedaría la integral
la integral de 0 a 1 de raíz de x de
raíz de x de x y ahí de ahí podemos
restar lo que queda por debajo de la
curva ya iguala x al cuadrado o sea esta
región de acá
y obtendríamos lo que queremos entonces
aquí es menos la integral de 0 a 1 de x
al cuadrado de x ok esto ya que es una
forma válida o sea esto sí nos va a dar
el resultado pero déjame pensarlo un
poquito diferente ya que estamos
integrando de 0 a 1
aquí y de 0 a 1 acá pues vamos a juntar
estas dos integrales en una misma
integral de la siguiente forma vamos a
ponerlas como la integral de 0 a 1 y
aquí le voy a poner de x de esta
expresión de raíz de x de raíz raíz de x
- x al cuadrado
x al cuadrado esto de aquí es válido
claro por supuesto es totalmente válido
sí pero que quería decir esto así
interpretando lo en el dibujo esta es
otra forma de pensarlo entonces vamos a
ver qué quiere decir no voy a marcar así
con color verde entonces vámonos para
acá una vez más tenemos rectángulos con
ancho de x entonces aquí tendríamos
pequeños rectángulos verdad con ancho de
x de x sin embargo ahora la altura de
estos rectángulos no es ni raíz de x ni
x cuadrada sino la diferencia así que
podemos pensar en estos rectángulos como
rectángulos que quedan así entre las dos
curvas ahí tendríamos un rectángulo por
acá otro rectángulo por acá otro
rectángulo y por lo tanto tendríamos
bueno o bien una aproximación o bien
cuando ya tomamos el límite cuando en
ese a infinito tenemos una infinidad de
rectángulos que son infinitamente flacos
y en efecto en efecto nos aproximan el
área verdad o se aproxima en el área
esta de acá que nos interesa
esta es otra forma de pensarlo entonces
una es pensando en estas alturas verdad
en la diferencia de lo que vaya una
función con la otra para poner la altura
de cada rectángulo o bien también
podemos pensarlo como lo hicimos al
principio que es utilizando las
herramientas que ya sabemos para
calcular dos áreas y restando bueno
vamos a continuar por este camino para
ver qué nos queda entonces eso es igual
a y vamos a encontrar la una anti
derivada para raíz de xy para x cuadrado
bueno x raíz de x x sala un medio
entonces tenemos que aumentar el
exponente en uno nos queda x a la tres
medios pero luego para que no aparezca
este coeficiente hay que dividir entre
tres medios o sea podemos multiplicar
por dos tercios entonces esto de aquí
sería el valor de la primera integral
definida que va de 0 a 1 ya eso vamos a
restar la de acá entonces una anti
derivada para x cuadrada misma idea
aumentamos el exponente en uno y
dividimos entre tres para que éste no
aparezca cuando derivamos
otra vez estaba de 0 a 1 ya nada más
quedan por hacer las cuentitas vamos a
ver qué nos queda ponemos igual así en
color blanco y seguimos con color
naranja
entonces evaluando en 1 evaluando en 1
nos queda 1 a la 3 medios que es 1 así
que es dos tercios nada más dos tercios
menos cero a la tres medios de cero aquí
nos quedarían dos tercios menos cero lo
pongo para saber en qué vamos ahora
vamos a estar acá
aquí nos quedaría otra vez 1 al cubo es
ahora hay que dividir entre 3 nos
quedaría un tercio y ahí restamos y
restamos están anti derivada evaluada en
cero que es menos 0 muy bien ya nada más
hay que hacer las cuentitas a ver que
nos quedan es una resta de fracciones
muy sencilla es dos tercios menos un
tercio que es un tercio y los ceros pues
no no no no colaboran con dar entonces
ahí está el área el área que nos
interesa es igual a un tercio y entonces
no sé qué unidades tengamos pero el área
aquí sería un tercio esas unidades al 4